[موسيقى]
اولا اود ان اشكر جميع البلدان التي قبلت
مهاجرين قصرا والموقف تجاههم في كل مكان
تقريبا دافئ جدا ويتم استقبالهم بكرامه
ولديهم فرصه للعمل ويمكن للاطفال الذهاب
الى المدرسه نحن ممتنون حقا لذلك
نحن نعلم ان هناك ازمه اقتصاديه في العديد
من الدول الاوروبيه ومن الممكن ان تكون
مرتبطه بالحرب في اوكرانيا لكن هذه فقط
نتائج العدوان الروسيه نتحدث عنها طوال
الوقت ليس بسبب اوكرانيا بل هذا بسبب
روسيا انها تضغط علينا بالسلاح وتضغط
عليهم اعلاميا واقتصاديا وتشعل نقاط عدوان
جديده في دول مختلفه وبين شعوب مختلفه لكن
شعبنا يشعر بانه طبيعي هناك وانا متاكده
انهم يعاملون بشكل جيد لو كان غير ذلك
فاعتقد ان المزيد من الناس سيعودون لقد
عاد الكثير بالفعل ولكن ليس كلهم مازال
عده ملايين من الاشخاص في الخارج نحن
ننتظر عودتهم
[موسيقى]
لا يمكن السماح لدوله اقوى باستيعاب دوله
اخرى لمجرد انها تريد ذلك سيبدا هذا
تفاعلا متسلسلا ويمكن ان يشعل الحرائق في
العديد من مناطق العالم لان هناك مناطق
حرجه في كل مكان هذا لا يمكن السماح به
الرجاء اختيار الجانب الصحيح والنظام
العالمي والسلامه يعتمدان الان على افعالك
[موسيقى]